you know I've long since believed that
doing things changes things doing
nothing keeps things exactly as they are
and the everything wrong with comic
series isn't a bad series but it's a
quintessential example of not really
doing anything just kind of sitting
around complaining and I never wanted
this channel to be a negative channel I
never wanted it to be a pleasure people
are just like me I don't want to go to
comments explain because all he does is
just complain about things he's just
upset about things all the time
I feel like if I've got a gripe surely
there's a solution for it and if it's
not easily found then maybe it takes a
little bit of digging making maybe it
takes a little bit of imagination to to
locate but once that solution is found
it can present itself as extremely
valuable maybe I have no business doing
this I don't know but I just want to
throw my hat in here and I want to offer
my own take on how to fix all-new
all-different marvel and some people
will say it's not broken but you can
look at the sales of Marvel's comics you
know you can literally track them since
the launch of all-new all-different
marvel the issue number ones sold well
because they're number ones number ones
always so well but going into the future
of story arts as we got into the issue
number three's and number fours and you
know sevens and eights the numbers were
just dropping down steadily just
consistently falling continually and
there's a reason for that a lot of
people feel like they were duped with
all-new all-different marvel a lot of
people felt like they were told this is
going to be all-new all-different marvel
and when it got around to crunch time
when it got around to put up or shut up
it wasn't all new and it wasn't all
different it was just a continuation of
what we'd seen before and maybe goes
because Marvel got cold feet maybe it's
because model didn't want to reboot
maybe it's because they never intended
to reboot they just wanted to drive
popularity for all-new all-different
marvel by calling it all new and all
different I have no real idea what was
going on behind the scenes but what I do
know is that as a person who's been
reading comics for 20 years I can't help
but be a little bit upset you know I
can't help to be a little bit angry
because for me is a comic book reader
and for those of you guys out there who
are watching this video right now who
are avid comic book readers and for
those of you guys who were casuals and
don't really understand where it is that
we're coming from we're passionate about
coming books because they are an
intrinsic part of our life the the
enjoyment the love that we have for
comics is the same love that surgeons
have you know for cutting people open I
guess it's saving lives
you know it's the love that teachers
have for educating a generation of kids
it's the love the gamers have for
playing RPGs and first-person shooters
and winning
money you know it is it's something that
we enjoy and we all got into it for
different reasons I've talked about this
before people got into coloring books
for a whole lot of different reasons but
the fact remains that whatever that
reason may be we are passionate about
comic books and if there's anything we
don't want to see it's the comics that
we love failing just not achieving the
level of success that they have been not
giving us the kind of good storytelling
that we like that we enjoy it's not to
say that we're entitled it's not to say
that we believe publishers owe us
something it's that we've seen a lot of
different changes over the course of
Marvel Comics and they have a rich
history and it seems with all-new
all-different marvel a lot of that rich
history is being thrown away so what I
want to do in this video is is again I
just want to dip my toe in the water of
this I want to start with spider-man I
want to start with all-new all-different
spider-man as it stands right now Peter
Parker and when all-new all-different
Oval was launched he became the Tony
Stark of the Marvel Universe and to be
honest it worked it was it was cool it
was an interesting story it's a
short-term story but it's an interesting
story the reason why I say it short term
is because of how I envisioned Peter
Parker because how I see him in the
all-new all-different marvel landscape
assuming for example that we don't
change anything hit bend in assuming for
example that the the incursion still
happened you know and that things
weren't rebooted so to speak you know
there were no new number ones you know
there was no fresh start or anything we
just kind of saw a continuation the
first thing you do is you issue an issue
number zero for Peter Parker you get
people caught up on his legacy
you get people caught up on his history
you don't just leave them hanging and
that was a problem with the with the
start of all-new all-different
spider-man it was like picking up with
the next issue of the last run there was
no real explanation there was no real
analysis there was there was no jumping
off platform for new readers it was just
hey either you understand what's going
on in this comic so you don't and if you
don't well then that's just your problem
you literally had to go back and read
superior spider-man in order to
understand horizon labs max Modell you
know all these different things that
were significant in the life of Peter
Parker and so my vision was this issue
number zero covers all that stuff but
instead of making Peter Parker the head
of parker industries you follow up with
the in a superior spider-man parker
industries is just kind of thing that
was fledgling but then it died out and
instead you make Peter Parker the head
of horizon labs for those of you guys
who don't know horizon labs was a think
tank of the smartest people you know the
smartest young people in the Marvel
Universe it was kind of like Reed
Richards Future Foundation and it was
headed up by a guy named max Modell who
was who is
extremely intelligent but he was kind of
an icon for Peter Parker you know Peter
Parker looked up to him as a
technological genius you know as someone
to aspire to with all-new all-different
marvel you pass that torch you have
Maximo Dell say hey Peter Parker look
like I've gotten married I'm starting
the next chapter of my life you are now
going to be in charge of horizon labs
Peter Parker can still be spider-man
that way one of the big issues right now
is that Peter Parker just really cannot
be spider-man just because of the fact
that he is a public figure in the comics
at this moment we have a guy named Hobie
Brown who's spider-man in his stead
granted Peter Parker is spider-man
occasionally but people don't really
read Peter Parker comics to see him be a
billionaire people read his comics to
see him be spider-man and that's where
the other half of the equation comes
into play
the fact that Hobie Brown is spider-man
right now takes away from the spider-man
title because people don't usually know
who Hobie Brown is and in fact unless
you've been reading Marvel Comics
hardcore you have no clue who Hobie
Brown is for those of you guys who don't
know he's a street-level villain turned
hero called the Prowler and he was a
c-list character invest put it this way
his claim to fame his biggest moment in
the history of Marvel Comics aside from
right now an all-new all-different
marvel was during the event of civil war
there was the first superhero to be
arrested after the deadline for the
superhuman Registration Act passed and
he refused to register he was the first
casualty of the Civil War conflict so to
speak and terms of being hauled off to
the negative zone that was his claim to
fame that was his biggest moment and Dan
Slott chose to make him the new Peter
Parker that's not what you do you look
to the legacy of spider-man you look to
the legacy of the character and 2000
model came along and they created the
ultimate universe and the ultimate
universe was designed to be a
reimagining of the mainstream Marvel
Universe it was designed to take the
continuity that we knew that had been
around since you know 1942 the Captain
America but achieved its most notable
success in the 1960s with the Avengers
and Fantastic Four and Thor and X minus
one and so forth and it was designed to
update those superheroes for the modern
times modern sensibilities to give the
generation of today something to read I
guess the generation on that time
something that they could relate to but
things were wildly different Nick Fury
was the original Super Soldier Captain
America was the second iteration of that
mutants came into existence because
Canada wanted to form their own
superhuman program they experimented on
Wolverine and discovered a gene that
when activated grants superpowers thus
mutants were born there were a lot of
huge changes but one of the most notable
changes and the realm of spider-man came
with the character of Miles Morales who
is created by Brian Michael Bendis and
Sara celli
and he was designed to be an updated
spider-man he was not designed to be
Peter Parker Peter Parker didn't exist
in the ultimate universe and there was a
storyline called the death of spider-man
and Peter Parker was killed off to make
way for Miles Morales to take his place
then the way that Bendis and Sir Bocelli
did this was incredible you know Peter
Parker was a huge influence on Miles
Morales even if only insofar that you
know miles saw him as a hero but when
Peter Parker died Miles Morales took up
the mantle of spider-man when he
encountered resistance from those
individuals who knew Peter Parker and
said you have no business wearing this
costume you don't need to do that you're
your dishonouring the legacy of Peter
Parker do not become him become
something else eventually people grew to
accept him but it was very much like the
dichotomy between Wally West and Barry
Allen after crisis on Infinite Earths
and this resonated great with the
character of Miles Morales because he
was a kid from a part of town that was
less than savory he dealt with his own
personal struggles day in and day out
there was a lot of buildup to his
character the issue is that the Ultimate
Universe was not nearly as popular as
the mainstream Marvel Universe because
when people think of Wolverine they
don't think of him as being the origin
of mutants they think of him as just
being a guy who's been around for a long
time he's got adamantium claws and he's
part of the x-men and he's in love with
Jean Grey when people think of Captain
America they don't think of him as the
second super soldier they think of him
as the original super soldier he fought
against Hitler during World War two he
fell into the to the English Channel he
was frozen for 20 years they brought him
back in the 1960s and he became part of
the Avengers because of this Miles
Morales was relatively popular in
certain circles but he was nowhere near
as popular as a mainstream spider-man
but when Jonathan Hickman started
writing the events of all-new
all-different marvel when he started
writing the events of secret Wars when
we believed the Marvel was going to be
rebooting there their entire continuity
Miles Morales was made an intricate part
of the story you could not go through
Secret Wars without knowing who Miles
Morales was he walked rank and file with
Peter Parker when you learned about how
the beyonders were defeated by the
combined efforts of Doctor Doom and
Doctor Strange and Owen reached the
molecule man you learned that alongside
Miles Morales and there was actually a
really funny moment when Miles Morales
gave molecule man a hamburger her gave
me a cheeseburger because of that
molecule man when reality was restored
to normal
basically brought Miles family back
which is a whole nother aspect of his
character but you can look at the
numbers when all-new all-different
launched and Miles Morales got his own
solo series it rose to popularity Vienna
was not nearly as popular as Peter
Parker but his he was selling better
than he was
during the Ultimate Universe line of
stories now whether or not this was due
to the fact that it was a solo Spiderman
book or because it's centered on Miles
Morales is simply a number I don't have
we'd have to go around to each
individual reader of that comic and ask
them individually why did you buy this
and that's a task that nobody would be
interested in doing but the fact remains
that when Miles Morales came back he was
just kind of shuffled off in no-man's
land with his own solo story you don't
do that Moz well it has the potential to
be as popular if not more popular than
Peter Parker's simply because of his
relatability because there were a lot of
kids from urban neighborhoods who could
identify with Miles Morales there are a
lot of kids who look at the relationship
between miles and his father the fact
that his father put so many restrictions
on and but does it to keep him safe the
kids could resonate with you don't get
this opportunity because miles is off
fighting his own adventures which is
fine but in my mind in my vision you
don't make Hobie Brown a stand-in
spider-man for Peter Parker you make
Miles Morales a stand-in spider-man for
Peter Parker that way Miles Morales gets
the exposure to fans that wouldn't
normally read his comics his
popularities beefed up but you also see
probably the most significant version of
spider-man in his publications not only
that because of the fact that Peter
Parker is head of horizon labs he's a
mentor for miles warehouse that was a
concept that was explored in the
Ultimate Comics and in fact there was a
story whereby Peter Parker from the
mainstream Marvel Universe met miles
Welles in the Ultimate Universe and
officially gave him his blessing and so
mozzarella's went forward as spider-man
you bring these two together you have
them fight side by side not only that
you use this series to lay the
groundwork for Civil War to which I'll
talk about in a later video but one of
the biggest issues that you would face
here is well if you've got a story where
you have two spider-man fighting at the
same time why do villains and how would
Doctor Octopus stand a chance how would
the jackal or Howard vulture or any of
those guys how would venom or carnage
those guys would be told easily well
sure if you kept them the way they were
but you update the villains they become
a little more intelligent they adapt to
two spider-men and they become just as
much of a threat as they were before but
again this is just kind of my my two
cents I'm just just sort of spitballing
here I'm just throwing ideas out there I
think that'd be a great direction to
take the spider-man series it would
literally just be a Miles Morales Peter
Parker tema and it would be a mentor
kind of situation it wouldn't just be
them fighting together so you get to see
the interpersonal relationships between
the two of them you get to see Peter
Parker looking at Miles Morales as a
protege and you get to lose see Miles
Morales living at Peter Parker as a
mentor but they would butt heads they
wouldn't agree on everything which would
lay the groundwork for civil war to
which I would see that as kind of a
story of the old superheroes versus the
new superheroes the young superheroes
again you know like I said you know I'm
just kind of throwing some ideas but let
me know down in the comments section
what you guys think about there so I'm
kind of curious I'm curious to see you
know how you guys feel about this sort
of a sort of idea but anyway we're going
to wrap this video up and yeah if you
guys are new to this channel feel free
to hit the subscribe button become part
of the rack or drop a like and I will
catch you guys later peace
[Music]
you